ينضم الينا من معبر رفح مراسل الجزيره
هشام زقوت لنقف معه على اخر تطورات هذه
الجبهه الجنوبيه لكن ابدا معك هشام
بالمعبر نفسه معبر رفح بعدما تحدث محامو
اسرائيل في محكمه العدل الدوليه عن ان
المسؤول عن دخول الاشخاص والمساعدات الى
غزه من معبر رفح هو الجانب المصري هل
هنالك اي تغير عند المعبر بعد هذه
التصريحات
اسرائيليه لا يوجد تغيرات في المعبر
المعبر من الجهه المصريه هي بكل تاكيد
السلطات المصريه هي من تتحكم في طبيعته
لكن من الجهه الفلسطينيه كانت حركه حماس
والحكومه في غزه هي من تسيطر على هذا
المعبر وتتحكم في الدخول وتتحكم في الخروج
بالتنسيق مع السلطات المصريه منذ بدات
الحرب الاسرائيليه قصفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه هذا المعبر ورصدنا من داخل
المعبر كيفيه ما الذي جرى والاضرار
الجسيمه التي حدثت في المعبر وعمليه القصف
التي ضرت البوابه التي تصل ما بين الجهه
الفلسطينيه والجهه المصريه وبكل تاكيد ما
في ظل هذه الظروف كان من المستحيل دخول
مساعدات دخول شاحنات الى الجانب المصري او
حتى من الجانب المصري الى الجانب
الفلسطيني بل وهددت السلطات الاسرائيليه
بقصف المساعدات التي تدخل دون تنسيق معها
و بالتالي كانت السلطات المصريه وقطر وال
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي الراعيه
لاتفاق فتح هذا المعبر من اجل في البدايه
من اجل اجلاء الرعايا الاجانب من ال من
غزه الى مصر ومن ثم الى بلادهم وبعد ذلك
من خلال هذه المباحثات سمحت السلطات
الاسرائيليه بدخول المساعدات من مصر الى
جانب الى الجانب الفلسطيني وفق اليه ب
بالزام وكاله غوث وتشغيل للاجئين الاونر
باستقبال هذه المساعدات من خلال اللجنه
القطريه التي مهدت الطريق من خلال الساحات
المتواجده
رفح على ارض الواقع لا يوجد للسلطات
الاسرائيليه اي تواجد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يسيطر على هذا هذه المساعدات ويسمح
بادخالها من خلال عمليه التنسيق ما بين
مصر الولايات المتحده قطر واسرائيل لكن
على ارض الواقع لا يجد اي طرف اسرائيلي
متواجد داخل المعبر لكن الطائرات
الاستطلاعيه تحلق في سماء المعبر الجيش
الاسرائيلي من خلال معبر كرم ابو سالم وهو
ملاصق لمعبر رفح تتواجد هناك كاميرات
ومناط وبالتالي هو يراقب كل ما يتحرك في
داخل المعبر تكنولوجيا الجيش الاسرائيلي
والاحتلال الاسرائيلي يسيطر على ما يحدث
في المعبر لكن لا وجود له على ارض الواقع
شكرا جزيلا لك هشام زقوت من
رفح